uh
oh really just to make sure
[Music]
49.
she gotta hook me
of his life
is
yes
[Music]
okay
bye
yeah it's always
here
thank you
please please ensure you are not
standing in the aisle
before
thank you so much
hi everyone all right full room
i hope everyone's cozy um
so today uh we are fortunate to have a
very special guest national
security advisor jake sullivan here to
join us and give a preview of the
president's
uh trip and then of course we'll do a
full briefing after that that'll turn
over today
thank you jen and thanks everybody so as
you all know this week
president biden will head off to europe
on the first foreign trip
of his presidency certainly not his
first foreign trip
but the first one is president of the
united states and the trip
at its core will advance the fundamental
thrust of joe biden's foreign policy to
rally the world's democracies to tackle
the great challenges of our time
we believe that president biden goes on
this trip from a position of strength
dramatic progress against the pandemic
at home strong projected growth that
will help power
the global economic recovery as well
renewed american power and purpose
and a rock-solid foundation of alliances
that will serve as for
force multipliers for our global agenda
at the g7 he will join with his fellow
leaders to lay out a plan to end the
copic 19 pandemic
with further specific commitments
towards that end
he will also join his fellow leaders to
announce a new
initiative to provide financing for
physical
digital and health infrastructure in the
developing world
a high standard climate-friendly
transparent
and rules-based alternative to what
china is offering
he and the other leaders will endorse a
global minimum tax of at least 15
percent as you saw coming out of the g7
finance ministers meeting a few days ago
and the g7 leaders will make a number of
significant commitments on climate
on labor standards on anti-corruption
and on ransomware
at nato president biden will address
enduring security challenges that have
been at the core of the alliance for a
long time
including russia and coordinating the
remaining period of the drawdown of
forces from afghanistan
but they will also focus on emerging
security challenges to the alliance
critically including cyber and the
challenge posed by china
president biden will also reinforce the
importance of burden sharing
not just the two percent commitment that
allies made back in 2014 at the wales
summit
but the need for allies to give not just
cash but
contributions to exercises and to
operations that nato is undertaking
and to have the kinds of capabilities
that make sure that nato is a full
spectrum alliance with allies across the
board providing the kind of high-end
capabilities
nato requires at the u.s eu summit the
president
and european union leaders will focus on
aligning our approaches to trade and
technology
so the democracies and not anyone else
not china or other autocracies are
writing
the rules for trade and technology for
the 21st century
president biden will also have a series
of bilateral engagements
including a u.s uk summit with prime
minister johnson
where the two leaders will reaffirm the
special relationship and
update and upgrade it for the modern era
and we will have further announcements
about additional bilateral engagements
that he will have both in cornwall
and in brussels in the days ahead
after his time at the g7 at nato
and at the u.s eu summit president biden
will go to geneva to meet with president
putin
he will do so of course after having had
nearly a week
of intensive consultations with allies
and democratic partners from both europe
and the indo-pacific so he will go into
this meeting with the wind at his back
now we have made clear repeatedly and i
will
reinforce again today that we do not
regard
a meeting with the russian president as
a reward
we regard it as a vital part of
defending america's interests and
america's values
joe biden is not meeting with vladimir
putin despite
our country's differences he's meeting
with him because of our country's
differences
there is simply a lot we have to work
through
we believe that president biden is the
most effective direct communicator
of american values and priorities and we
believe that hearing directly from
president putin
is the most effective way to understand
what russia
intends and plans there is never any
substitute for leader to leader
engagement particularly for complex
relationships but with putin this is
exponentially the case he has a highly
personalized style of decision making
and so it is important
for president biden to be able to sit
down with him face to face
to be clear about where we are to
understand where he is
to try to manage our differences and to
identify those areas where we can work
in america's interests
to make progress when president biden
returns to washington next week we
believe
that we will be in a materially stronger
position to manage the major threats and
challenges this country faces
covid climate china cyber russia
and shaping the rules of trade and
technology for the future
so with that i'd be happy to take any
questions that you have yeah
thanks jake is this the right time to be
having a one-on-one meeting with
vladimir putin
so early in president biden's presidency
before he's met one-on-one with so many
other
world leaders and at a time when there
isn't a specific
deliverable that the white house is
looking to achieve from the one-on-one
meeting
so first we don't think in terms of u.s
russia summits
uh as being about deliverables because
if you're
going to wait for really significant
deliverables you could be waiting a long
time conceivably
so what we need to think about this
summit is doing is fundamentally giving
us an opportunity to communicate from
our president to their president
what american intentions and
capabilities are and to hear the same
from their side
that has value in and of itself secondly
in terms of the timing
it is hard from our perspective to find
a better context for a meeting with the
russian president
then after time spent with the world's
leading market economies the g7
plus india south korea australia and
south africa
after a meeting with all of his fellow
leaders at nato after a meeting with the
presidents of the european union
and then and only then going into this
session to be able to talk through the
complex set of issues in the u.s russia
relationship that from our perspective
is the right context within which to
engage russia
and as far as whether it comes too early
in his presidency if you think about
what we've dealt with
from the outset on russia it's been a
busy time we've extended the new start
agreement we've imposed costs for
election interference
and for solar winds we've dealt with a
russian buildup
on the ukraine border and of course we
are contending with a range of issues in
the cyber and ransomware domain so
we feel that it is an effective and
appropriate context and time period for
us to have this summit to that the
ukrainian president
did an interview today and implored
president biden
to meet with him first before mr biden
sits down
with vladimir putin is that something
that you're considering if not why not
well actually i've come into this
briefing room
from the oval office where uh president
biden was on the phone with president
zielinski of ukraine
uh this is a call that they had been
planning to make
in advance of president biden going to
europe meeting with president putin they
had the opportunity to talk at some
length
about all of the issues in the u.s
ukraine relationship and president biden
was able to tell president zielinski
that he will stand up firmly
for ukraine's sovereignty territorial
integrity
and its aspirations as we go forward and
he also told president zielinski that he
looks forward to welcoming him to the
white house
here in washington this summer after he
returns from europe
yeah yeah hi jake thank you um we know
that
afghanistan is going to be discussed
with our nato
allies there's been a lot of concern
about replacing some of those u.s
assets uh such as the drones to be able
to fight against the taliban
can you bring us up to speed on where
are the negotiations with pakistan
and would the united states like to have
a drone base in pakistan
so i'm not going to get into the details
of our negotiations with pakistan i will
only say this we have had constructive
discussions
in the military intelligence and
diplomatic channels with pakistan
about the future of america's
capabilities to ensure that afghanistan
never again becomes
a base from which al qaeda or isis or
any other terrorist group can attack the
united states
but in terms of the specifics of what
that will look like
uh that will have to remain in those
private channels as we work through them
what i will say
is that we are talking to a wide range
of countries
about how we build effective
over-the-horizon capacity
both from an intelligence and from uh
a defense perspective to be able to
suppress the terrorism threat in
afghanistan on a going forward basis
um two questions one with putin and one
here back at home
with putin the president is going into
this
uh meeting where there's great tension
between both leaders
and let's talk about the trust factor
how can you trust anything
vladimir putin says in this sit down
when the president comes back and saying
you're going to learn
what he's thinking and what he wants to
do moving forward
how can you trust that as vladimir putin
has already smeared
the president's name how can we do that
i can trust
taking the measure of another president
is not about trusting them
and the relationship between the u.s and
russia is not about
uh relationship and trust it's about a
relationship of verification it's about
a relationship
of clarifying what our expectations are
and laying out that if certain kinds of
harmful activities continue to occur
there will be responses from the united
states and our
well we will lay those out for president
putin in this meeting and he will
understand fully where the united states
stands and what we intend to do
but one thing i will say april is we
believe fundamentally that our capacity
to ensure that harmful and disruptive
activities against the united states do
not continue
unabated is to be able to communicate
clearly directly not by negotiating in
public
but by explicating our position and our
capabilities
in private and that's what president
putin is the second question
on voting um the fourth people's act um
if it is not passed what is the national
security
uh issue with it is there a national
security issue if it's not passed
because we've heard so much over the
past
few years about issues of voting if that
is not passed is it a national security
issue
i would say the basic notion of
democratic reform and voting rights in
the united states
is a national security issue we are in a
competition of models with autocracies
and we are trying to show the world that
american democracy and democracy writ
large can work
can effectively deliver the will of the
people and to the extent that we are not
updating refurbishing revamping our own
democratic processes and procedures to
meet
the needs of the modern moment then we
are not going to be as successful in
making that case to the rest of the
world to china to russia or to anyone
else and so
there is a national security dimension
to this today just as there was through
the decades of the cold war
thank you so much um my question is can
you talk a bit about how president biden
plans to
convince especially our european allies
that president former president trump
was an anomaly in some ways
all of the things that he did to in some
ways traumatized those leaders
calling into question the need for nato
what's the plan there and is he
concerned that those scars are going to
be deeper than
his ability to address them in this one
trip i think our view going into this
trip is that actions speak louder than
words and that's showing that the united
states is capable
of turning the corner on the pandemic
showing that the united states is
capable of making the dramatic
investments that will pull us
up and out of this economic recovery and
help power global growth
showing the world that we are ultimately
capable of making the investments in r
d and infrastructure innovation and
workforce ultimately setting that
foundation for this country will be the
most effective way to show the rest of
the world that the united states
has the power and purpose to be able to
deliver as the world's leading democracy
so that's what he's going to try to uh
demonstrate and he as i said at the
outset feels he goes into this
from a position of strength because of
the record he's built up over the course
of the first four months
is congress being briefed on the idea
of voting in the national security issue
and if the for the people act is it
passed
what will that say globally given the
fact that you just laid it out at the
national security issue
so i will say humbly as the national
security adviser i
don't tend to get into the middle of the
debates up on the hill on
issues like voting rights all i can say
is the bottom line principle
not a specific question about the
vehicle or the
um or the time frame but rather the
fundamental principle
which is that a strong vibrant american
democracy that protects
voting rights is the best way for us to
make the case to the world that our
model and not some other model
is the right model to actually vindicate
the will of the people here in the
united states
and for other democracies to be able to
do the same thing yeah uh
two quick questions one to follow up on
the biggest concern of some of our
allies
has been over the last four years and
even before just the rapid swing back
and forth of
our foreign policy now you can't assure
anyone what's going to happen after you
leave but what insurance is what will
you tell
our allies that despite what we've seen
in the past
that have returned to normal i think the
best way to answer that question
and and this builds on what i said to
yamiche
is what president biden can do
is show the rest of the world what
america is capable of
if we can lead the world in ending the
covet 19 pandemic more
rapidly if the growth we are powering
for the american people here at home
helps power a global economic recovery
if we can help rally as the president
did with his climate leader summit
action on climate on the climate crisis
so that we actually beat this thing
ultimately that is going to be the best
way for people to say
man the united states can do this they
can deliver and we will stand up and
stand behind them
and that is the uh the approach that he
has taken from the first day he's been
in office
that's the message he's going to carry
into these meetings and what i believe
we will deliver just out of the g7 alone
in addition to the other meetings he's
going to have on this trip
will show that the united states retains
profound capacity to help rally the
world's democracies to solve big
problems
the second question was will you look at
ransomware as a national
security priority how will we address
that in the g7
yes ransomware is a national security
priority particularly as it relates to
ransomware attacks on critical
infrastructure in the united states
and we will treat it as such in the g7
we will treat it as such
at every stop along the way on this trip
yes
um what is the point of meeting putin in
person if there are no
deliverables and there's no real trust
to that relationship
um why does the president think in
person is the most effective way to
address putin you could just do this on
a thumb
well first of all there's no substitute
for face-to-face engagement in any
dynamic he's not just going to geneva
right he's going to cornwall he's going
to brussels
he will have the chance to look in the
eyes of literally dozens of leaders over
the course of his time
and all of that will be better than just
operating on the telephone that's
not the other leaders if there's well
but
centered around these issues that are so
complicated what does this president
believe
what does he believe he can bring to the
table with putin and
how does he assess putin as a leader
that he could talk to across the table
so first the reason i answered with all
the other leaders is this isn't
something unique to putin
meeting face to face is not just
something you do with vladimir putin
it's something president biden
is going to do i think all told when you
add it up with somewhere approaching
35 or 36 uh leaders just on this one
trip alone and he has welcomed the prime
minister of japan and the president of
korea he will welcome
other leaders here over the course of
the summer because face-to-face
engagement is just of a different order
of magnitude of diplomatic engagement
from doing it over the phone
second um on this notion of deliverables
in the u.s russia summit
at the end of the day what we are
looking to do is for the two presidents
to be able to send
a clear signal uh on question to their
teams on questions of strategic
stability
so that we can make progress in arms
control and other
nuclear areas uh to reduce
tension and instability in that aspect
of the relationship
and then second being able to look
president putin in the eye and say this
is what america's expectations are this
is what america stands for
this is what america is all about this
we believe
is an essential aspect of u.s russia
diplomacy because
president putin is a
singular kind of personalized leader and
having the opportunity to come together
in a summit
will allow us to manage this
relationship and stand up and defend
american values most effectively
following up on the ransomware issue
given how pervasive
it is has been for some time u.s
officials have talked about the need for
international allies to work together on
this issue are you looking for specific
commitments from allies what do you want
to come out of the g7 and nato summit
with as it pertains to ransomware to
help better protect the us
so one of the things we'd like to see
out of the g7 is the start of an action
plan that covers a number of critical
areas
first how to deal with the
increasing the robustness and resilience
of our defenses against ransomware
attacks collectively second how to share
information
about the nature of the threat among our
democracies third
how to deal with the cryptocurrency
challenge which is
lies at the core of of how this these uh
ransom transactions are played out uh
and then finally how we collectively
speak with one voice to those country
countries including russia
that are harboring um or permitting uh
cyber criminals to operate from their
territory so those are some of the
things that
we are looking for as outcomes out of
the g7 plus
we will also speak in the nato context
about
cyber threats particularly as they
relate to critical infrastructure
as being of a different order of
magnitude of security threat that the
alliance has to concern itself with
in a way that it hasn't historically but
it's got to become a priority on a going
basis yeah thank you so much thank you
thank you so much
okay so about the infrastructure
financing program that you were talking
about going to be announced
which countries in the united states and
just having look at
brazil one of these developing countries
to
receive this financing and if you could
update us about the
discussions with brazil on 5g because
today we have a delegation from brazil
here discussing the nsc er
nfc officials and finally why
hasn't president biden is still talking
with the brazilian president
personally why he hasn't and what is the
message this
sent to brazil's june he's already going
to for our international trip
he has not yet speak with brazil so why
is that
so there are a number of leaders that he
hasn't had the opportunity to speak with
and
one of the reasons why of course as many
people in this room know is he's had an
unbelievably packed and crowded
agenda particularly domestically and
trying to beat the pandemic
and get on the road to covet 19 recovery
so he's looking forward
to making sure he gets to touch the
leaders of every significant country in
the world
over the course of the coming weeks and
months on 5g
we have made clear our view and we will
communicate that
with the delegation visiting from brazil
that we believe that trusted vendors for
5g are the best way
both for to secure telecommunications
networks and to ensure
that a country's democratic values can
be protected and then finally
i'm i'm not going to get ahead of the
announcements uh
on the financing for for infrastructure
package uh i will let that speak for
itself but i will say it will cover all
of the significant regions of the world
including latin america and the
caribbean
thank you thank you um
when the united states rejoined the
world health organization you wrote in a
statement
that meant quote holding it to the
highest standards uh does that mean that
the world health organization
has failed to meet those standards at
some point and then what specifically
is this administration doing to make
certain that that they are held
to those standards so we have made
clear uh from the beginning of this
administration and in rejoining that we
believe the who does need to be reformed
some of those reforms are more
programmatic and bureaucratic they
relate to ensuring
greater efficiency and effectiveness in
responding to things like the outbreak
of covet 19.
some of them are about making sure that
there is not undue influence or
interference by any single member state
or country in the who and then some of
them relate to very targeted issues like
the covet
19 origins investigation where i have
personally and we collectively
have been quite vocal about our view
that there needs to be a second round to
this investigation that truly gets
to the heart of the matter which is the
original data and original information
that is still being withheld by china
and our hope is that in the coming
months we will
see a credible international
investigation progress
uh including in respect to those items
yeah thank you jake
what is your expectation for when the
u.s will lift
travel restrictions on the uk and on
europe and what are your
current concerns why haven't they been
lifted yet what specifically are you
looking for to have happen for that
to happen well let me start by saying it
doesn't really matter what i am looking
for
personally because at the end of the day
this is a process being driven by
science and public health guidance and
so
it is ultimately up to the public health
professionals in the us government to
make that determination
we have heard very clearly the desire
of our friends in europe and in the uk
to be able to reopen travel across the
atlantic ocean
and we want to see that happen but we
have to follow the science we have to
follow the guidance of our public health
professionals so we are
actively engaging with them to determine
the time frame
and i can't give you a date today but i
will tell you that
we recognize the concern and we are
fundamentally being guided by objective
analysis in this regard
what is your response to arguments that
those continuing restrictions on the uk
and european countries
are unfair given that there are other
countries that the us does not have
travel restrictions on my view on this
is we have been transparent and clear
about the basis
for our travel restrictions we have done
so through a process that has been
guided by science and evidence
that is how we've determined uh how the
travel restrictions have been applied
and to whom and that is how we are going
to proceed on a going forward basis this
could this administration's commitment
to that kind of analysis is fundamental
it is what has guided every aspect of
our response to the pandemic including
this issue thank you very much
nice to see you and jennifer with the
usa to
korea and learning about the north korea
issues
is there a possibility of
u.s and south korea japan through a lot
of the meeting at the g7
and you're discussing with the north
korean issues
we don't currently have a trilateral
schedule between the u.s japan and south
korea but i will tell you there's a
possibility for virtually anything in
these small spaces where you have just
uh
you know in this case 10 or 12 liters in
person there in cornwall
uh but there's nothing currently on the
schedule uh
logistical question actually do you
expect president biden and president
putin to spend any time together
alone or do you expect that staff and
aides will be present
throughout all of this summit and can we
expect a joint
press conference between the two leaders
and is this something that you're
actively pushing for
all of that is still being worked out so
when i've got more to report on the
modalities both in terms of how the
meeting will be structured and the press
elements will come back to you thank you
yeah i want to ask you about that
specifically with two leaders
it was announced last week that the
president will have a bilateral with the
turkish
presidential religion i know that talks
have been challenging
with him um can you describe what the
administration's hoping to accomplish
out of that and also secondly um with
the uk
uh what is the dynamic what's the
personal relationship
between boris johnson and joe biden
we've heard about the special
relationship between the two countries
what's their relationship so uh
president biden and president johnson
are prime minister johnson have had the
opportunity to have a couple of phone
calls
and those phone calls have been warm
they've been constructive they've been
very
much down to business they've gone
through extensive agendas in both of
them
and i expect that their meeting together
will just cover the waterfront i mean a
really wide range of issues
where uh the the two of them and the us
and the united kingdom do see eye to eye
they've been collaborating on this plan
to end the pandemic they've been
collaborating on this
infrastructure financing plan they've
been collaborating
on virtually every aspect of the g7
agenda and
they talked very closely about
how the leader summit that president
biden hosted on climate
could help provide the runway into cop26
which prime minister johnson will be
hosting in
uh in glasgow and then as far as uh
president erdogan is concerned they will
have a bilateral on the margins of the
nato summit in brussels
and there too it's going to be a broad
and expansive agenda
issues right there in the region of
course in the eastern mediterranean with
syria
with iran nagorno-karabakh but also
the role that turkey will play on a
going-forward basis with respect to
negotiations and diplomacy in
afghanistan
and how the u.s and turkey itself
deal with some of our significant
differences on values and human rights
and other issues and president biden
knows erdogan very well the two men have
spent a good amount of time together
and they are both i think looking
forward to the opportunity to really
have a business-like opportunity to
review the full breadth of the
relationship i'm afraid
i have to go i'm sorry guys
we asked you one question about ukraine
sure and whether uh the president
zolensky
mentioned his ask to have ukraine join
nato what message did the president
deliver in response if it came on
so uh they were able to talk about
basically every significant aspect of
the relationship
including with respect to uh the us's
support for ukraine's security
but in terms of the specifics of what
they discussed i'm going to let
the two of them speak for themselves i'm
not going to read out that aspect to the
meeting
thank you okay
um all right well what a good way to
start off a full
briefing room our first full briefing
room day since the president took office
um
a couple of updates for all of you at
the top over the weekend the department
of health and human services released
new data that showed
more than 31 million americans have
gained access to quality affordable
health care through the affordable care
act
a record high that demonstrates the
strength durability and
impact of the historic law after years
of relentless attacks on americans
health care president biden also
reunited with president former president
obama
for the white house's weekly
conversation to share the news discuss
how the administration's special
enrollment period
has allowed more than 1.2 million
americans to enroll in health coverage
and highlight how the american rescue
plan has lowered premiums and health
care
costs another update from the weekend
over the weekend the g7 finance
ministers also endorsed
president biden's plan for a global
minimum tax of at least
15 percent this is a historic
unprecedented
progress made possible by the
president's and secretary yellen's
commitment
to a global tax system that is equitable
and equipped to meet the needs of the
21st century
global economy the g7 endorsement is
another example of america
reasserting its leadership on the world
stage something we look forward to doing
later this week
and establishing a global corporate
minimum tax will help level the playing
field for the united states
ensure fairness for the american middle
class and working families everywhere
and focus competition
for business where it belongs uh last
item for all of you
today the department of justice
announced two new steps to stem the
epidemic of gun violence in our country
following through on the president and
attorney general's announcement in april
of a set of initial actions
first the doj has issued a notice of
proposed rulemaking
to strengthen regulations on stabilizing
braces
and that that help convert pistols into
dangerous short-barreled rifles
which it appears the perpetrator of the
boulder shooting used now that we know
more
the department is also publishing model
legislation and guidance
that will make it easier for states to
implement red flag laws
something that's already law in a number
of states across the country which
studies have shown can be effective in
reducing gun violence including by
preventing suicides
and even potential mass shootings this
is part of the president's long-standing
commitment
to addressing the scourge of gun
violence which continues to claim
far too many lives every single day josh
kick us off i'm very thrown off by
reverend seated i'll adjust to it
okay go ahead thanks jen uh two
questions
first senator manchin laid out the
argument that election reform should be
bipartisan
because anything partisan would quote
destroy the already weakening binds of
our democracy
does the president agree with that
sentiment or is that sentiment
untenable because the state level
changes being pushed by republicans
well first let me say that the president
knows he was elected uh
to deliver on deliver for the american
people
and his view is that that includes
making voting more
accessible for people across the country
making it easier and not harder
to vote and he's made clear that there's
a real need for federal legislation
to protect the sacred right to vote uh
and we are not going to wait for
congress either that's why we've taken
some steps
uh through our department of justice and
also why we've
he's asked the vice president to lead
this effort both in
working with congress but also at the
state level because as you noted there
are a number of problematic laws that
have been moved
have moved forward in states across the
country
i think where we are at this point is uh
clearly uh senator manchin has stated
his point of view
in his opinion piece over the weekend uh
which many of you it sounds like have
read
as did we uh but the president's view is
that
uh we need to move forward not just with
the john lewis voting rights act but
also with legislation
uh like the for the people act uh which
enjoys i should note broad support for
from the american people
and because it does a couple of things
that he thinks are essential
uh it provides basic professions for
registering to vote and how we cast a
ballot
it will prevent politicians from drawing
congressional district lines for
partisan advantage
to ensure that people are choosing their
representatives it will help end the
corrupting power of money in politics
now in terms of the path forward and
what that looks like and the mechanics
of
how it moves forward in congress the
president is quite open
to and willing to work with anyone to
enact common sense reforms that benefit
the american people
we will stay lockstep with democratic
leadership on what that looks like
from here uh but i don't have anything
to preview about the next steps and then
secondly
the justice department has had a series
of policy changes
with regards to his relationship with
reporters and
uh pursuing reporters sources and
possible prosecutions
and i was wondering under this
administration would the justice
department
still be trying to compel reporters to
name sources
or anonymous or unnamed important would
they continue to do that
well i think that the announcement from
this weekend or the statements from this
weekend which were entirely consistent
with the president's
uh comments he made just a few weeks ago
make very clear
um that going forward consistent with
the president's direction the department
of justice
in a change to long-standing practice as
many of you have noted and here before
will not see compulsory legal process
and leak investigations to obtain
source information from members of the
news media doing their jobs that is
entirely consistent with delivering on
the president's comments just a few
weeks ago entirely
consistent with his policies now it
doesn't mean there's still it's an
independent justice department
they will proceed of course with a range
of investigations which
as we noted in our statement on saturday
morning we did not know
about the uh gag order until minutes
before
the reporting came out on friday night
so that's appropriate
but at the same time moving forward
consistent with the president's policies
they will not be proceeding with those
actions that have been consistent over
the last several years
go ahead steve is not happy with the
capital county
what happens now on infrastructure uh a
couple things steve
uh one uh first the president i expect
will speak with senator capito
before he leaves on his trip today or
tomorrow i know we noted monday
in our readout on friday but we're
looking to schedule that call and it
will be prior to his departure on
wednesday morning
as we noted also in our statement on
friday the offer did not meet the
president's bar
of growing the economy tackling the
climate crisis and creating
new jobs and i would remind all of you
both in our
counteroffer but then in a lot of your
reporting it's clear the president has
come down by about a trillion dollars
uh what is what we've seen on the other
side is they've only come up
by a small percentage of that uh so
look moving forward he's looking forward
to having a discussion with senator
capito today or tomorrow
um and he uh certainly is eager to see
what what what can what that discussion
can entail
uh knowing that in any discussion any
negotiation
both sides come closer together that's
always the objective
he's come down quite a bit we're looking
to see more now at the same time
there are a lot of paths forward here as
many of you know even though our muscles
have atrophied a bit
uh on this on this front one is um
congressman defazio as we noted in our
readout on friday as well
is marking up leading the markup of the
house legislation that has a lot of
overlap with the american jobs plan this
week
uh and a lot of it's a that is a path
that has a lot of opportunity to move
forward in the house as we know
sometimes the house and the senate
may move forward on different paths and
we've seen that take place on lots of
pieces of legislation
the third pathway i would just note is
there are republicans and democrats who
have been out there talking about
their eagerness to be a part of this
discussion and a part of an
opportunity to move forward on the
president's bold ideas and historic
investment in infrastructure
so we'll look forward to seeing uh what
they have to offer and what what
conversation we can have with them so
all of these paths uh we expect to
continue to make progress on this week
what is the status of a semi-conductor
review should we expect that today
tomorrow when exactly soon steve i would
expect you will have more this week i
know there is a lot of interest and
eagerness
on hearing what the status of the review
is and any policies that have will come
out of that review
go ahead and go ahead and research your
back on that does the president have an
agreement with senator manchin that if
the
bipartisan tax fails the mansion will
support the uh using
reconciliation construction certainly
not going to speak on behalf of where
senator manchin is
obviously he's spoken to his interest in
making historic investments in
infrastructure he's also spoken to his
openness to
raising the corporate tax rate those are
all positive signs in our
view we'll let him speak for himself on
where he stands on any pieces of
legislation
go ahead given the concessions that you
just outlined the president has made so
far should we expect this to be the
final round of negotiations
the center capital i think we have to
see where the conversations uh go over
the next day or so we're certainly not
going to prejudge them again
look the president has come down by
approximately a trillion dollars
we'll see where the conversation
goes when he has the opportunity to
speak with senator capito
and there are a number of paths where we
can move these ideas forward at the same
time
you mentioned your support for this
markup that's happening on wednesday
is that a signal should we read this as
some kind of signal
to your republican counterparts that you
are ready to go this alone
i think it's only just a statement of
what's happening as a bill becomes a law
which is that a leader in the house is
moving forward with marking up a piece
of legislation that has
quite a bit of overlap with the american
jobs plan the president proposed
so the time is not unlimited here as
we've stated from the
them from the beginning nor is the
president's willingness to
compromise he has areas where he wants
to see greater investment
he made clear that the the proposal the
alpha put on the table didn't meet his
own bar
but we're very open to where the
discussion goes from here and
uh he's looking for the app looking
forward to the opportunity to talk with
senator capito as well as
others who may come forward uh with
ideas about how to move this forward and
just one
more on this sort of big picture
secretary but a judge had said that by
today you would hope to see
a clear path on infrastructure do you
have a sense that there is
an emerging clear path we have several
paths that's the good sign
go ahead is there a new deadline that
the president has set for progress on
infrastructure i know
there you know there was memorial day
now you're outlining a few different
paths is there a time at which he's
going to make a decision about which one
he's going to take given
that the deadline keeps moving well
first of all what we said is by memorial
day we would hope to have a sense of
where it looked like moving forward and
we do
we have a couple of paths forward we
don't know what the end outcome will
look like as you typically don't
as a bill is moving its way to becoming
law
and there are several paths forward as
i've noted so we're going to continue to
work on all of those lines i would also
note that speaker pelosi has said she
wants to move forward with
legislation on infrastructure in the
house in june that's exactly what's
happening here
uh leaders leader schumer said he wants
to move forward in july
again the house and senate can be on
different timelines and pathways
on the voting rights did mention give
the white house a heads up that this
op-ed would be coming out did you guys
have any sense of
how firm his position was on this
legislation i'm just not going to get
into any
channels of private conversation with
senator manchin or any other senator
the vice president obviously you know
last week the president said that she
was going to take a leadership role
yeah in voting rights uh democrats have
warned uh
that if you know washington doesn't take
action that the
midterms will be quite difficult uh
given the changing
voting laws is is there going to be a
more you know are we going to see signs
of more urgency from the white house
about taking action
on voting rights obviously the president
has had a lot of lawmakers in the oval
office
to talk about infrastructure will we see
more signs of
an increasing focus on trying to make
progress on voting rights
absolutely but i would also note that
early on in the
the presidency the president signed into
law an executive order that
put in place a number of uh positive
steps forward on voting rights uh
something an action he could take
without congress
uh we've also empowered the department
of justice of course to
take actions to implement some of these
policies so we're not waiting
uh i would also note that the fact that
he asked his vice president
well or he they agreed i should say
since it was her ask but
that she would lead this effort moving
forward tells you what a significant
priority it is for this white house as
you know she's currently on a trip to
the northern triangle
she'll be back and i'm certain you'll
hear more from her soon go ahead
go to you next april i promise look i'm
just jumping around so i don't forget go
ahead bigger picture one
more drill down on infrastructure uh
what's the president's message what's
your message to
democrats particularly progressives who
started to get a little bit antsy that
you know the windows closing we went
through this back in 2009
it's time for us to move it's not just
infrastructure if you don't move
infrastructure the rest of the four
trillion dollar agenda doesn't move
either what's
how does the president have calling that
doubt i think
i think his message is uh he remains
absolutely committed to moving forward
with a historic investment in
infrastructure
and also to put pushing forward the
american families plan that will help
level the playing field lift up the next
generation of workers
ensure there's universal pre-k and
access to free community college
these are all initiatives that he has a
commitment to moving forward on and part
of the discussion which we talked about
a little bit last week
is also about tax reform and ensuring
there's a way to pay for
a range of these ideas it's not that one
is uh assigned by a blood oath to one
piece of
uh you know one one piece of the agenda
is assigned
to one piece of a pay for there's
opportunity to
move forward with several components of
the president's agenda we do have time
we're not going we're not using the
timeline of the affordable care act as a
model here
phil but as you know and anyone here
knows it it takes time to move these
things forward to get
democrats on board to get republicans on
board ultimately we're looking to have
enough of a coalition to move forward on
these bold
historic ideas uh and we we obviously
don't have that at this moment but we're
working toward that
and then just drilled out a little bit
on the on the two knife markup i mean
this is service transportation package
most republicans are cool to it right
now can you elaborate how that is a
pathway a viable pathway forward
given you're looking for a bipartisan
path there you know kind of what the
thinking is behind that markup and that
piece of legislation well i think it's
important to note primarily because
it has a great deal of overlap with the
american jobs plan
uh and certainly it provides an
opportunity for democrats and
republicans to vote to support a
historic investment infrastructure
obviously
a markup is just the beginning stage of
the process there's some time to go
uh but it's important to note because it
is a piece of legislation that's moving
its way forward even as these
negotiations are continuing
oh i'm sorry april you're right i'm
sorry go ahead yes back from the issue
of voting rights
um you said the president uh issued some
executive orders on voting rights but
they don't deal with the issue
of uh shelby versus holder 2013
when it comes to pre-clearance so
how do you equate that well i wasn't
intending to equate it the question
earlier was broadly about voting
right it was not about whether or not
it's essential to move forward with
legislation that would make
voting more accessible ensure that
everyone knew that every vote was
counted
i think it's important to know and
understand the president doesn't feel
that uh you know the john lewis voting
uh act
voting rights act is a replacement for
uh before the people act
and that it is necessary to move forward
with more than that
and a follow up on that um tomorrow joe
mancha's meeting it's reported
he's meeting with civil rights leaders
civil rights leaders who
pretty much align themselves with this
administration and what are your hopes
because i mean they seem like they could
be your last hope if there is any hope
to move him on his opposition against
what people act well look i i don't know
that i can speak to
a meeting that has no member of the
administration is participating in april
but i can tell you that
the president is going to continue and
as our members of this administration
have been leading this effort from
susan rice as to cedric to anyone who's
at the highest level and obviously to
the vice president when she returns
from her trip uh to advocating uh for a
path forward on how we can
ensure that everyone knows their vote
counts uh that we make voting more
accessible that we make it easier not
harder
those are fundamentals the president the
vice president other members of the
administration
will be open to eager to have that
discussion with anyone who wants to be
constructive in that moving forward
his heart will change i'm not going to
make a prediction about senator
manchin's position on an issue i'd point
you to him to speak to that
go ahead on the same topic could you
speak more to the
uh actual argument that senator manchin
was making which was less about the
content of the for the people act and
more about the fact
that it doesn't have bipartisan support
and that
being behind it would be wrong for that
reason alone
well i think the president's view
continues to be that
making a voting uh easier for people
making it easier to vote ensuring people
have
access to that fundamental american
right
should be something that democrats and
republicans all support
and he certainly will continue to
advocate for that
i don't know that i have more of a
comment on senator manchin's position
i'd point you to his spokespeople for
that and then
given the fact that we've been talking
about how a bill becomes a law if he's
against the for the people act does that
mean that for all intents and purposes
at least
right now it is dead i'm certainly not
going to make that prediction as you
know there can be many ups and downs of
legislation moving forward and as i
noted earlier he's been the president's
been clear he's willing to
work with anyone to enact uh common
sense
reforms that benefit the american people
that make it easier to vote
he'll have those discussions with
democratic leadership and we'll work
together on what the path forward looks
like
go ahead thank you 19 origins china has
basically already said they think their
part
in an international investigation is
done so why is jake sullivan still here
saying he thinks it's
possible that they're going to provide
the preliminary
data at some point well i don't think we
just give up that easily
we are can continue to press in
coordination with the international
community
china to be transparent to be
forthcoming with data and information
we're not going to just stand by and
accept that they've said they're not
going to participate now at the same
time as you know
we're also launching our own review and
our own process and i'm certain this
will be a topic of discussion as the
president goes overseas this week and
when you say that the
white house is going to continue to
press what is that what what is that
what is present
well well okay
what mechanisms what steps are we taking
to press
sure we are engaging certainly at the
highest levels and we'll continue to do
that uh whether it's the secretary of
state
or other leaders who engage on through
national security diplomatic
conversations
and we will continue to work through the
who and also with our international
partners
uh to uh exert that pressure and ensure
that uh we're all going to keep pressing
for them to release
date underlying data and participate in
the second stage of this investigation
and then just quickly a housekeeping
thing
presidents bush obama and trump all
commemorated
d-day anniversaries on d-day on the
d-day anniversary
why didn't president obama well i can
tell you that certainly the
uh vali his value for the role that men
and the men who served
on d-day uh and the memory of them uh
the families who have
uh kept their memories uh alive over the
course of years on this
day is something the president has spoke
to many many times in the past
um it's close to his heart and i
wouldn't be surprised if there's more
we would have to say on it go ahead jen
how do you say you don't want to read
out any private conversations
but it certainly seems like the
president and senator manchin are
sending messages to one another in the
public you had the president last week
expressing some frustration about he
didn't name him but senators in his
party who vote with the other side you
have
the op-ed from senator mentioned this
weekend
are these two men on the same page does
the white house
feel like it understands and knows what
senator mentioned wants adam's
particularly infrastructure talks uh and
can you say when
how often these two have been speaking
with one another if not in person by
phone
well i can certainly tell you that the
president and senior members of the
administration are in close senator
manchin
and his team about infrastructure and
about a range of issues
where there is an opportunity work to
work together moving forward
i'll also note that i'm pretty sure
senator manchin
is pretty proud of his independent
streak uh and he made clear he took no
offense to
the president's comments last week and
he also noted i think over the weekend
that
west virginia doesn't usually get this
much attention so
uh maybe it's a uh you know that's
something he doesn't seem to mind too
much
to see senator mentioned as potentially
an obstacle to his agenda if he follows
through on
not backing changes to the filibuster uh
not wanting to pursue
uh infrastructure through reconciliation
that pretty much grounds the
president's domestic agenda at this
point well we're certainly not ready to
accept that
uh that analysis i will say the
president consider senator manchin a
friend
he knows that they may disagree on some
issues as they do
on uh this particular piece of
legislation he's going to continue to
work with him reach out to him engage
with him directly
and through his staff on how we can work
together moving forward
you mentioned the video of president
obama and president
over the weekend one of the remaining
supreme court decisions we're waiting on
deals with the affordable care act can
you talk about the white house's
preparation
for that decision what we would expect
to hear from the white house
if they strike down the former president
certainly uh we'll reunite it and it
feels so good for but the vice president
and former president
someone gets us in here okay um so even
a full room no laughs okay
um look i will say that um this is one
of the rules that uh nier tandon who has
come in
uh as a policy advisor is playing is
planning for what the contingencies are
as you well know
we don't know what day this is going to
come out or what the outcome is going to
look like
and what we are staying rooted in is our
fundamental view the fundamental view of
the president and the vice president
that
uh the american people deserve access to
affordable care health care we should
continue to
improve and build upon the affordable
care act and
uh that's how we're planning for uh but
you know there's a range of options i'm
sure when we know the outcome we can we
can speak to that more directly go ahead
andrew thank you thank you
uh so you you've answered a number of
questions about uh
voting rights and people casting their
votes i want to ask you about
counting the votes a number of the bills
that have passed republican legislatures
and
are pending before republican
legislatures take
the voting and the counting of votes and
the running of elections out of the
hands
of nonpartisan officials and put them in
the hands of republican
state legislatures this is what donald
trump
wanted done during the run-up to when
congress certified president biden's
victory
this is what a lot of scholars are
saying republicans
as all are preparing to do in the event
democrats
win close elections in 2022 and 2024
the florida people act does not address
the issue of
counting the votes and rigging or
ignoring the counting of votes if the
democrat wins
how much of a concern is this
to the president and what what's he
going to
do to highlight this and find a solution
well andrew it's a really important
issue to raise and as you've noted
there are pieces of legislation putting
the federal effort aside
that are moving their way through state
legislatures which would make it
uh part a partisan in some scenarios in
some cases
uh put the hands in the power of a
partisan decision-making body or
individual and
clearly that's concerning uh we noted in
the announcement about the vice
president's role is that
her effort would be focused partially on
federal legislation and moving that
forward seeing what pat
the path looks for it looks like moving
forward but also
working with voting rights groups
working with state activists working
with others to
see how we can address these challenges
it is a priority it is a focus
um and again the president's fundamental
view is that it should be easier
to vote not harder and that we should
ensure that everybody knows their vote
is counted
support congress amending the electoral
count act
i i'm happy to see if there's any
specific statement of administration
policy we have on that particular piece
go ahead francesca thanks john with the
president leaving the country on
wednesday
is that the cut off time for talks with
senator capito's group or is he
advising staff while he's gone to
continue negotiations with those
republican senators
well i would expect certainly things
will continue we don't know again we'll
we'll see what the conversation looks
like when the president speaks with
senator capito today or tomorrow
but either way uh the president will
certainly empower as he has
his jobs uh jobs you know jobs
cabinet to continue to engage directly
with
members of congress and leaders to
continue to move
his agenda forward the other piece of
good news is that
any white house is pretty well practiced
and continuing to operate
and work on domestic issues while
they're traveling overseas and i expect
the president will remain engaged
uh on the american jobs plan even as
he's overseas meeting with a number of
global counterparts go ahead
how about senator romney is he one of
the republicans that you've alluded to
that the president
and the white house are also having
conversations with uh he has
senator romney has spoken uh publicly
about his interest in engaging so
certainly he'd be a person we'd be happy
to
have that conversation with and there
are certainly others as well go ahead
thanks jim if i can go to the vice
president's trip to the earlier
yeah we'll stay for a minute um what's
different about these
this announced initiative that just
landed in our inbox from the justice
department especially from what was
already announced from homeland security
a few weeks ago in terms of
anti-smuggling anti-trafficking is that
just to give the vice president
something to point to today
given that there isn't going to be
additional aid announced in the northern
triangle and
if one more thing how do you respond to
criticism from experts
as well as the administration's own
border officials who say that the title
42 policy is actually
contributing to and exacerbating
smuggling and trafficking
at the border with people trying again
and again taking more dangerous routes
kidnappers literally waiting at ports of
entry
well first i have not seen what the
department of justice just announced so
i'd have to take a look at that
i will say that um the the purpose of
the vice president's trip
is to meet directly with counterparts in
these countries to discuss how we can
work together on
uh reducing the number of people who
want to make the journey
uh to our border uh and well in terms of
the due outs of that or what will be
announced i will certainly leave that to
her team
to announce on the ground but that's
broadly the purpose
but go ahead go ahead one more uh jake
just said that um
in regard to francesco's question about
a travel restriction yeah he said
that the administration's going to be
following the science following the
public health experts
uh there was reporting over the weekend
that cdp has now been told twice that
the title 42 policy was going to be
lifted in march and in may there's also
reporting that part of
the vice president's trip is pushing
mexico to take back more
migrants and asylum seekers or expelled
from the u.s you've got public health
experts including at the cdc saying it
serves no help
public health purpose um so all of this
seems to indicate that it's not actually
about public health it's about
immigration and political optics well
actually what jake was referring to is
the overall guidance by the cdc and
there may be individuals who have
different points of view
we certainly understand that within the
cdc or other places but we're talking
about
what the overarching recommendation is
from leadership
uh and through their own uh thorough
process so that's what jake was
referring to
on those restrictions on the southern
border i don't have any sense of the
timeline on that quite yet
uh go ahead thanks jen um to meet the
president's goal of 70
of americans vaccinated july 4th uh
there needs to be about 4.2 million
adults per week vaccinated
last week there were 2.4 million
indicating a slowdown in the number of
vaccinations is there any concern
that the president's goal will come
close
high 60s would not meet 70 well first i
would
say we expected a little bit of a
slowdown because of the holiday
um but it is there's no question it's a
bold and ambitious goal it's one of the
reasons that
we launched this month of action uh to
ensure that we were using every tool
at our disposal to push these numbers up
i'll also note that
regardless of where we are on july 4th
we're not
shutting down shop on july 5th we're
going to continue to press to vaccinate
more people across the country so
what we're looking at there's a couple
more things here are a couple of factors
uh one there's a difference in data as
you all know as it relates to age right
so over people who are over
40 have a much higher percentage of
vaccination than people under 40. so
clearly some of our
focus needs to be on people under 40 for
this period of time
and this push we've also looked at the
fact that there are about 12 or 13
states who've already met this 70
marker uh so we're going to continue to
push through the finish line
through the red tape here not the finish
line through the red tape to july 4th
uh but i can't make a prediction weeks
and ahead of time where we will be
we're just going to use every um every
tool at our disposal to get there and
then one more
morning right sure where does the
president feel
the vice president can best be used i
know that her office has made an
emphasis that this legislation is only
one
little piece not little it's huge but
only one piece
of her work on voting rights so does he
see her as somebody who can
be out in the country drumming up
support you know alongside
civil rights groups and private
corporations like where does he see her
strengths
as a politician fitting into this issue
yes all of the above
um and as she noted in her statement
when this was announced
she intends to be engaged with voting
rights groups and community activists
with leaders in states as well as on the
federal level and i think the important
uh component of that or the important
note of it is uh
even as we're continuing to move or
press and advocate for
legislation on a federal level there are
other areas where we can have an impact
i expect when she gets back from her
trip
we'll hear more from her on this uh go
ahead uh
i wanted to get a point of clarification
on an earlier question okay
as it relates to the supreme court in
the health care case does that mean that
the white house is starting to think
about plan b
legislation in the event that a plan b
legislative path is necessary
uh you know i think we are near tanden
again is leading this effort and we are
planning for a range of contingencies of
what the outcome might look like
but i'm not going to outline that quite
yet and on the surface transportation
uh bill yeah i mentioned working its way
to the house is that a signal that the
white house the president's okay with
sort of breaking up
these proposals and the little bits and
kind of just getting what you can get
along the way over a much longer period
of time than
maybe this june and july grand sort of
legislative path that the democrats are
on
he has always been quite open to a range
of mechanisms for his bold ideas moving
forward
uh so certainly uh that's been his
approach from the beginning and
continues to be
uh what his view is on mechanics
thank you jim you know let me
ryan you got a question before so let me
i'm going to abide by josh here but let
me just do like two in the back because
there's new people here who have
who have not asked any questions go
ahead in the back uh
thanks jen i want to ask you a couple on
infrastructure your statement that you
put out on friday afternoon
you said that the president indicated
that the offer did not meet his
objectives to grow the economy
tackle the climate crisis and create new
jobs on the climate crisis component
can you outline what the president
believes needs to be in an
infrastructure package
and a bipartisan deal on the climate
front well i think what that is a
reference to
is investment in areas like ev buses and
ev charging stations and some of the
components that are essential to
investing in industries of the future
and ensuring that we're creating
millions of jobs
while also doing it in a way that
protects our climate
i'm not outlining must-haves here i'm
outlining what the president would like
to see more of in a piece of legislation
okay let's do one more last in the right
there we're
right behind the green shirt green
please yes go ahead
hi jen um i wanted to ask you going back
to the tax proposal
from over the weekend part of that was
talking about
um the where large market multinational
corporations are
taxed yeah do you have an estimate at
this point of what that would look like
for revenue for the us
of the components the president put
forward in his proposal or which piece
sorry
the global minimum tax or the other part
of it
the book and the book yes it's in our uh
it's in our budget
it's outlined in detail in our budget
which is public i'm sure we can get that
to you after the briefing thanks
everyone so much let's do this
you all again tomorrow deadline for when
you'll get a grand coalition together
and you set one for yourself somebody
asked a similar question yeah but it
wasn't answered
you